Je me disais,
quand t'es avec des gens,
c'est toujours super gênant
de s'isoler pour aller aux toilettes.
Enfin, quand tu vas faire pipi,
ça tu le dis.
Par contre, quand on doit
aller faire plus que pipi,
c'est-à-dire qu'on doit faire [pouet pouet],
bah ça, on le dit jamais.
Et donc il a acheté une moto et le truc,
c'est qu'elle était trop lourde pour lui,
du coup il arrivait pas à —
mais ouais, voilà, c'est ça !
Bah, Norman, tu vas où ?
Ah, je reviens, je vais faire un truc.
Non mais, comment ça,
tu vas faire un truc ?
Je vais faire un truc, j'arrive !
>> Bah allez, dis-nous, c'est pas compliqué !
Tu peux nous dire !
>> Réponds, Norman !
>> Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire ?
Bon, OK, je vais faire caca !
Comme ça !
C'est bon ? Tout le monde
est au courant ? Je peux y aller ?
Merci !
C'est vrai que c'est la honte
d'aller faire [pouet pouet].
C'est pour ça que moi,
j'essaie de faire passer
tous mes passages aux toilettes
pour des pipis.
Malin !
Quand je vais chez une fille,
je ne fais jamais [pouet pouet],
parce que j'ai juste une angoisse,
c'est que la chasse d'eau ne marche plus.
Oh non !
Parce que, forcément,
t'es obligé de lui dire !
Heu, Vanessa, euh, je crois
que ta chasse d'eau marche plus.
Ouais, elle est cassée.
>> Ah ! Et comment je fais pour la...
Ah bah je vais te montrer.
>> Non, non, mais je vais le faire.
Non, mais t'inquiète !
>> Non, non, mais en fait, faut pas que t'y ailles !
OK. Donc c'est toi qui ... ?
>> Ouais. Ouais, c'est ça, voilà.
Cette femme ne couchera jamais
avec toi de toute ta vie !
Moi, si un jour ça m'arrive,
je quitte le pays !
D'ailleurs, quand t'es en couple,
au début de la relation,
c'est toujours très gênant d'aller aux toilettes,
alors qu'il y a ta copine,
parce que ça casse
le côté romantique.
Cependant, il existe des petites techniques,
notamment deux.
La première, c'est de mettre
un max de PQ au fond de la cuvette.
Assez classique !
La deuxième, qu'on a déjà tous faits, c'est de
mettre la musique à un volume assez puissant,
de manière à bien camoufler
tous les bruits.
J'arrive, je reviens.
Mais moi, à ce moment-là,
j'ai toujours peur
qu'il y ait un stop dans la musique
pile poil au moment fatidique.
Noooonnn !
Et puis, quand t'es en couple, il y a toujours
ce fameux débat autour de la cuvette.
C'est chiant, parce que moi,
quand je lève pas la cuvette, on me dit :
Norman, tu peux lever
la cuvette quand même !
Et quand je lève la cuvette,
on me dit :
Norman, tu peux baisser
la cuvette, quand même !
Donc moi, j'ai trouvé une solution :
la cuvette semi-relevée.
Heureusement, les smartphones
ont réussi à faire
ce que les femmes essaient de faire
depuis près de 100 ans :
faire pisser les mecs assis.
Vous le savez peu-être pas,
mais dans les urinoirs, nous,
on fait pas que faire pipi.
On joue aussi à des jeux.
Yes ! 500 points !
Bonsoir.
Tss !
Un autre truc super gênant
quand t'es posé aux toilettes,
c'est quand tu reçois
un appel professionnel sur ton portable,
et que genre,
t'es obligé de décrocher.
Tu sais, dans ce cas-là,
tu peux pas dire que t'es aux toilettes.
Tu sais, ça fait pas pro.
Allô ?
>> Monsieur Thavaud, je ne vous dérange pas, j'espère ?
Non, vous me dérangez pas,
par contre je fais caca.
Hein, vraiment, j'ai très, très envie.
Est-ce que je peux vous rappeler plus tard ?
Surtout qu'il y a des bruits
de prout qui vont arriver.
Moi, une fois, comme ça, j'ai décroché.
Mais j'aurai absolument pas dû.
Ouais, très bien, est-ce que
vous avez de quoi noter ?
Là tout de suite,
je peux pas noter, non.
Comment ça ?
Parce que je sais pas écrire.
Moi, je sais que lire, en fait.
J'ai fait que la moitié du CP.
Je sais pas si vous avez déjà eu l'occasion
de tester les toilettes publiques dans les villes,
mais les mecs qui ont créé ça, ils ont
quand même eu l'intelligence, la bonne idée
de mettre une petite voix qui commente le choix
de ta chasse d'eau quand tu sors de la cabine.
Nettoyage en cours. Vous avez sélectionné
le mode grande chasse d'eau.
Félicitations, ça devait être
une très grosse envie.
À bientôt dans les toilettes publiques !
Oui, c'est la petite voix des toilettes
publiques qui vous parle.
Apparemment, vous avez choisi
la grande chasse d'eau.
Vous êtes en direct sur NRJ !
Félicitations !
C'est pour ça que moi, j'y vais même pas
dans les toilettes publiques en fait.
Moi, je fais pipi dans la rue,
comme un gros porc.
Partage ma vidéo
sur ton mur Facebook.
Swag ! Swag ! Swag ! Swag de poule !
Un discours ! Un discours ! Un discours !
Moi, à ce moment-là,
je deviens hyper timide
et le seul discours
que j'arrive à sortir c'est :
hum, merci !
>> Ouais !